all right everybody it's mailbag time it
is uh that time of the week where i look
through the mailbag we are now getting
man what are what are we up to
we get about a thousand emails a week
now i would say uh like actual emails
you know some people say uh
total number of comments we're we get
like four to five thousand comments a
day if you include tweets facebook
comments instagram comments instagram
messages youtube comments everything
together
email someone actually taking time to
email info davidpakman.com it's about a
thousand a week and i want to highlight
some different things for you here today
all relevant in some way as a reminder
if you are new to this program new to
our environment
one of the things that i've just
accepted as part of doing this as as my
thing
is uh really horrible people write to me
and bill for example wrote to me
and said show my email on your youtube
page
you effing jew
f and then that second f is the you know
the pejorative for a gay person
um this is every day so every day of the
five thousand
100 to 150
are this type of thing this is the world
we live in we can't just say hey you
know what david i disagree with you
about how taxes should be organized no
it's
you effing jew f
does not bode well for society
this is not making me think we're very
close to achieving
some greater level of understanding and
problem solving by working together no
it doesn't seem that that's the way it's
going to go
next email who pays you
i sort of love this question in a way
because you know sometimes this question
is overtly anti-semitic like what
take your soros jew money and stop
pushing communism you know whatever um
but it's actually i i love the way that
we're organized which is our number one
funding source is people in our audience
it's just people people who ask the
question
it's people like you not you but people
like you that pay us through our
membership program and yeah you know
we're part of youtube's monetization
program facebook's when they allow us
we've got some advertisers etc
but basically we're viewer funded
and um
that's a great thing because there's no
one person that can say david unless you
do or say x we're gonna pull your
funding if one member comes to me as
they sometimes do and recently did which
we'll get to in a moment and says david
unless you take exposition i'm pulling
my funding well pull your two bucks a
month pull your 60 a year or whatever
nobody has this under their thumb
because so many different people fund us
so that's who pays us and it's a really
really great thing okay a lot of
controversy surprisingly i guess
over the pronunciation of the capital of
ukraine
one such person wrote to me and said
david it's pronounced kiev
and then a couple hours later they wrote
back and full respect to them they said
my apologies i just checked it you're
right the back story on this and the
reason why we now say kiev and spell it
k-y-i-v
is that
much like in well what's a good example
this isn't a perfect example but you
guys know how the name weinberg in
english sometimes you see it spelled
w-e-i and sometimes it's w-i-e
sometimes it's w-a-i and at the end the
berg part sometimes it's b-e-r-g
sometimes it's b-u-r why why is that
well it's being
it's it's it's being translated
um from languages hebrew yiddish which
don't always put the vowels in so it
really it's the root it's the the w and
w n b r g and the vowels sort of don't
matter so there's different ways you can
do it and similarly when it comes to
kiev
for a while it was a more anglicized
spelling k-i-e-v and when people looked
at k-i-e-v logically they said that's
kiev
it was eventually updated and npr and
other media outlets
announced when they were doing this they
said you know really the the more proper
spelling would be kyv
in translating from the cyrillic
and uh as a result we're also going to
be calling it kiev which is more in line
with the actual ukrainian pronunciation
so this is actually this this is a years
old story because of what's going on in
russia ukraine now more people are
talking about it and gladly so all right
i told you there are people
pulling financial support and looking to
hurt us very badly
and a lot of those people like tulsi
gabbard we actually do have a fraction
of our audience that likes toolsie and
they don't like that last week i said
tulsi is a confirmed scam or grift or
whatever
and so one such person is robert robert
wrote to me and said dear david at least
he's polite dear david i have
unsubscribed from your show because you
reveal
your our tribal your our tribal you look
for labels and you follow the liberal
official narrative tulsi gabbard speaks
to citizens of all labels calling us to
remember our common ground is far
greater than our pet peeves be well wake
up robert robert has cancelled his
membership that's right robert pulled
his six bucks a month and so what i'm
asking you is if you don't like this
kind of stuff i would love for you to
sign up on our website joinpakman.com i
think there's many more people in our
audience who support what we do
and understand the toolsy scam
than the people like robert who are
trying to hurt us financially
for making that assessment
vincent wrote in vincent said dear david
thank you for speaking the truth about
tulsi gabbard she's been spreading lies
and russian propaganda since the
beginning and it's important to counter
those lies keep doing what you're doing
best vincent
thank you vincent and i will tell you
the vast majority of the feedback to us
saying guys
if you fell for the tulsi scam it's over
just say you were wrong and say you're
going to do better next time you you now
have learned it was a mistake but you
learned and now you won't fall for
similar scams in the future
overwhelmingly people reacting very
positively to that very positively
people uh saying things like what
vincent says every once in a while
though someone like robert cancelling
his membership comes through
next email is from cindy cindy has an
idea about how to refer to trump
she says i have an idea i would love to
see it catch on
maybe if you would it would if you would
use it every time donald trump refers to
someone who opposes him or an
organization that opposes him he loves
to use the word failed in front of their
name or title like the failed new york
times
failed gubernatorial candidate whoever
what if instead of referring to him as
former president donald trump we started
referring to him as failed presidential
candidate donald trump truthful accurate
and utterly triggering love what you do
keep it up yeah i think um
i like this idea i'm gonna make an
effort and sometimes it's really hard to
kind of use the the lexicon that one uh
tends to use i'm gonna make an effort to
say instead of former president donald
trump i'm going to say failed president
donald trump because he did fail and he
failed by his own standards it's not
just my assessment from the left that he
failed the things he said he would do he
never did he said he would build a wall
across the entire u.s mexico border he
didn't do it
he said he would fix trade he didn't do
it he said he would put out a beautiful
replacement plan for obamacare that
would be great for everybody not only
did he not get that done he didn't even
tell us
what the plan is or how it will work
remember in august of 2019 it was two
weeks away i think from coming out it
never did
by his own standards by his own
standards he is a failed president so
cindy i like the way you're thinking i'm
going to try to refer to trump as failed
president donald trump
a bunch of people writing to me about my
rant about electric vehicles last week
someone emailed or left a voicemail
rather and said david most electricity
still comes from fossil fuels so our
electric car is really better i laid out
a ton of reasons why they are but i
missed some reasons and rickard
wrote in and said david just listen to
you explaining why electric cars are
better are the better environmental
choice compared to gas powered
everything you said is valid i want to
add another argument which will make it
much more tangible i used to own a volvo
v40 because i'm swedish
makes sense it's a small hatchback
comparable to a small sedan it consumed
roughly half a liter of diesel per 10
kilometers which translates to 5
kilowatt hours
i now own a tesla model 3 and it
consumes 1.6 to 2.3 kilowatt hours per
10 kilometers in other words the tesla
is much more energy efficient this means
even if all the electricity produced
from powering electric cars
was produced by burning diesel it's
still more efficient to use electric
cars and i totally missed this and this
is a really good point we can say well
you go a hundred miles
with gap burning gas or you go 100 miles
using electricity derived from burning
coal either way it's fossil fuels
but the point here is the efficiency of
doing it through electricity is
significantly higher even accounting for
the heavier vehicles because the
batteries are heavy that's a really
really good point from rickard and then
one more here
similar idea from mark
mark wrote in and said david love the
segment about switching to electric and
renewables but you miss the big point
even if one hundred percent of
electricity was generated by burning
fossil fuels
the power plants are more than four
times as energy efficient
versus the gas-powered engine in your
car keep up the good work so a similar
idea which is if you have all of the
burning of gas happening in a hundred
thousand cars
that has one level of efficiency in
converting that fossil fuel to movement
in the vehicle
if it's done centrally at a power plant
and then distribute it out via
electricity it is more efficient in
terms of how much fossil fuel
consumption there is for moving those
hundred thousand cars
some distance ten miles a hundred miles
whatever the case may be so
i understated i understated the relative
efficiencies
of electric vehicles um in the segment
last week but so many people are in our
audience very keyed into that and loved
the opportunity to say more about it if
you have an email you can email info
davidpakman.com it may be selected
remember we get about a thousand a week
we feature 10 so those are those are the
odds uh
make of it what you will
and uh we have a fantastic bonus show
coming up for you today sign up at
joinpackman.com we will see you then